bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors je le disais un les
huit militants du collectif réquisitions
sont poursuivis par la justice pour
avoir fait irruption à l'hôtel dieu avec
près de 70 sans abri vous comprenez leur
décision de ne pas se rendre à leur
convocation au tribunal
écoutez oui d'autant plus que j'en fais
partie donc étant donné que j'étais avec
ces personnes sans abri et nous
demandions à l'ap-hp ou à la préfecture
de mobiliser une partie des ailes de
l'hôtel dieu c'est internet
oui des ailes d affecter nos pme qui
sont très nombreux aujourd'hui puisque
je crois que l'hôpital ne tombe plus
aujourd'hui qu'à un quart voire même de
ses capacités donc il y avait la
possibilité là de loger en urgence
plusieurs centaines de personnes à la
rue que de laisser dehors dans le froid
et dans des conditions terribles de vie
puisqu'on était pendant la vague de
froid
donc c'est pour ak c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous sommes rentrés dans
l'hôtel dieu sommes restés d'ailleurs au
rez de chaussée dans la partie je dirais
ouverte de l'hôpital nous n'avons pas
gêner les activités hospitalières
surtout pas et donc finalement là la
préfecture de paris a organisé
l'hébergement de ses 70 personnes
donc voilà on a amené on va dire
l'action de solidarité et de la plainte
de l'ap-hp des responsables associatifs
qui était dense est dans cette
initiative est bien a été nous a surpris
en fait puisque nous sommes rentrés
pacifiquement tranquillement il ya eu il
n'y a pas eu de heurts de contact c'est
la porte est ouverte voilà c'est un
gosse vous vous en voulez aux autorités
de vous avoir poursuivi vous et les sept
autres militants pour cette action là
écoutez on entend un peu comme un
message
c'est d'ailleurs nous nous un message
d'intimidation c'est à dire arrêter les
actions que vous menez qui je le
rappelle ont permis avec l'occupation
hier d'un gymnase du gymnase japy dans
le 11e arrondissement l'hébergement
depuis janvier la mise à l'abri
là la mise à l'abri mais de plus de 1000
personnes sans abri donc si vous voulez
pour nous on mène une action qui pose en
fait à rappeler à l'état ses obligations
que la loi prévoit que toute personne
sans abri peut faire appel au 115 et
doit être accueillie et ensuite orientée
non pas remises à la rue mais orientée
vers une structure d'hébergement ou de
stabilisation ou un logement
donc si vous voulez le sait la loi
écrite comme ça tel que je vous l'a dit
et elle existe depuis 2002 et
malheureusement les violet n'est pas
respectée on a aujourd'hui beaucoup de
logements vacants
on à 3,1 millions de logements vacants
et et la loi de réquisition n'est pas
appliquée elle pourrait s'appliquer sur
les biens publics semi-publics
appartenant à des grands propriétaires
des immeubles de bureaux qui sont vides
et c'est franchement il ya de quoi loger
en urgence des personnes à la rue parce
que vous voyez laisser des gens dans la
rue c'est vraiment les laisser mourir à
petit feu ceseda merci vous pourquoi le
gouvernement ne le fait pas alors de
reloger ces personnes sans abri si il a
les moyens de le faire pour nous il ya
un manque de volonté
c'est une évidence il ya aussi sans
doute une posture idéologique c'est à
dire ondrais on n'applique pas la loi de
réquisition
mais que ce soit une loi d'ailleurs qui
a été appliquée par des parts d des
présidents plutôt de droite un de gaulle
jacques chirac
on comprend pas très bien d'ailleurs
cette position-là de refus de dire bon
bah écoutez là pour l'instant on n'a pas
de place ailleurs donc on va les mettre
ici en attendant de construire des
logements sociaux de faire en sorte que
tout le monde puisse être logés
dignement c'est inadmissible d'avoir des
hommes des femmes des enfants des
personnes handicapées des personnes
âgées des personnes qui se laissent
progressivement j'irai tomber dans la
dans la désolation et le désespoir
et alors que l'on a à trois millions de
logements vacants
c'est pour ça que vous organisez des
opérations coup de poing du type de
l'hôtel dieu pour forcer quelque part le
gouvernement est bien à agir et à m
appliquer la loi de réquisition
oui la loi de réquisition et surtout
pour faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus que
l'on laisse plus les gens dans la rue
c'est bien de ça qu'il s'agit c'est ça
notre objectif
après il ya plusieurs possibilités si
gouvernement à des locaux à disposition
actuellement ils m'aident près de 3
milliards pas loin de 3 milliards
d'euros pour payer des hébergements dans
des hôtels etc
donc nous on propose en plus une
solution qui est qui et moins coûteuses
et moins onéreuse c'est c'est aussi
simple que ça et puis ce qu'il faudrait
c'est que le gouvernement applique la
loi et puis pour nous il s'agit des
berges et les gens qui font appel à nos
associations les paupières 56 solidarité
migrants wilson paris exil etc et à
trouver des solutions pour eux un
dernier mot jean baptiste eyraud
peut-être sur la fin
la trêve hivernale au 31 mai qu'est ce
que ça signifie ça pour eux pour les
sans abri là ça signifie à nouveau la
remise à la rue parce que c'est la fin
des hébergements en fait pour les sans
abri c'est le début des expulsions la
remise à la rue des sans abris et les
coupures d'énergie
donc voilà c'est une période qui est
giresse et une date fatidique pour les
mal logés les belles et tous ceux aussi
qui ont eu du mal à payer leur loyer à
cause de deux épidémies qui ont perdu
leur job elle ressources et qui se
retrouve aujourd'hui en croatie re
d'expulsion il faudrait il faudrait
impérativement et on suspend l'exécution
toute l'année on aide les gens à à payer
résorber leurs dettes de loyer pour nous
il faudra à purée d'être de loyer comme
ça a été fait pendant la commune de
paris par exemple là et puis également
faire en sorte que le logement
redeviennent accessibles dans notre pays
parce que la cause l'augmentation
constante du nombre de sans abri
c'est vraiment la cherté du logement
le logement est trop cher dans les
villes dans les grandes agglomérations
etc
et voyez-vous les prix des mobiliers et
des loyers on continue à augmenter
pendant la pandémie
c'est pour dire ce qu'ils ont ceux qui
ont du patrimoine secteur de la richesse
gagner encore plus d'argent aujourd'hui
que qu'il ya un an c'est pas là ayrault
juste un dernier mot pour terminer vous
vous souvenez de cette phrase d'
emmanuel macron je ne veux plus d'ici la
fin de l'année à voir des femmes et des
hommes à la rue qu'est ce que ça vous
fait donc d'entendre ça trois ans après
alors que le emmanuel macron payet à la
fin de son mandat il lui reste plus
qu'un an maintenant à tenir
ô combien je m'en souviens c'était en
juillet 2017 et donc nous avons
nous avons avons pris au pied de la
lettre mais le nombre de sans abri
continue d'augmenter et le nombre de
sans abri dans des rues
voilà malheureusement et sont là sous
nos yeux et ils seront si le
gouvernement ne suspend pas les remises
à la rue ils seront des dizaines et des
dizaines de milliers de or à partir du
moi de partir du mois de juin pour ça
qu'il manifestons aussi contre les
expulsions pour la baisse des loyers
pour le droit au logement le 30 mai à
paris et aussi dans toute la france sur
des manifestations pour de demander le
respect du droit au logement que le
droit au logement viennent dans la
constitution en fait c'est ça la
question
parce qu'on criminalise les laisse clé
les occupants les squatteurs et cetera
il ya des lois qui arrivent et qui dure
six et qui prévoit d'envoyer est ce que
vous pensez qu envoyé en prison les gens
qui sont sans logis et qui s'installent
dans des logements vacants c'est une
solution s'agit pas d'aller s'occuper de
s'installer dans des résidences
principales de résidents secondaires
c'est pas du tout de ça que je parle je
parle des personnes qui sont menacées
aujourd'hui par des lois par une loi qui
est soumise au conseil conditionnelle et
qu'il prévoie de criminaliser à trois
ans de prison et 45000 euros d'amendé
les personnes qui s'installent dans des
locaux inoccupés dans des locaux vacants
et donc ça là on va vraiment vers une
criminalisation de la pauvreté ce n'est
pas acceptable c'est comme si on
criminalise l abbé pierre
eh bien ça sera le mot de la fin jean
baptiste eyraud merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
porte parole de l'association droit au
logement
merci